bien dit il
les abîmes bas rhin le début pas fait le
rivage de 0 à 200 il ya le coût de la
vie un patient infecté
il ya ce revers par méduses sèche ce mot
information sur la mer et tournées sur
les océans est homo ou là espadon
ce que j'attendais
j'attendais surprise les hommes via
l'état et l'église explique le
déroulement et de l'espoir
là c'est un peu comme un dictionnaire
pour dire alors que les autres
et bah c'est une histoire avec bailly
chars avec les personnages eux-mêmes qui
a vraiment de nomades
j'ai bien aimé inscrire dupiol était
belle
de la nature cherche une perle
c'est plus être bien fait c'est bienvenu
[Musique]